so such a honor to be standing here
representing my team and the people that
allowed us to tell this beautiful story
so I want to start thinking Jack Adam me
for this recognition and is amazing week
it was a was incredible and I want to
start thinking my family I think without
their love and support I wouldn't be
here today I have my brother and RAM
please gisela for now that they are
representing everyone and I have to also
thank my parents by Miami tova god oh we
got to do mundo on postage mice it was
Portuguese and i will now i would like
to thank now the people they made the
film with me start with my producer best
friend and also wife dies thank you that
is and producers alexa sabrina and
katrell cinematographers Alejandro and
guanxi production sound Charles Missouri
and sound design Veronica composers are
like the same and also have gia i think
is here too he it was an additional
camera and everyone that helped us make
on making this film and i want to thank
my professors at USC for everything they
taught me especially my mentor I'm in
the Pope and que demain and Mark Harris
thank you very much and and finally I
have to think the people they open their
hearts to us and and really let us tell
the story and it was really a privilege
for all of us Thank You jaisa Fernanda
and says and everyone at the ballet
Association for the blind and thank you
very much meat obrigada